good morning Hank it's Tuesday and as
you can tell from the great speckled
walls behind me in a stirring turn of
events I am in an airport I have to go
to this big book on France called ba and
give a bunch of speeches and I'm super
nervous but it's question Tuesday the
day that I answer real questions from
real nerdfighters let's get right to it
hard tacos or soft tacos burritos would
you ever consider doing a video upside
down what do you mean like this or like
this I could do this but the people in
the airport are looking at me kind of
weird
oh hey whatever happened to the
abundance of katherines cover contest
actually that's part of the reason I'm
going to New York I get to announce the
winner on Thursday and reveal the cover
is I'm so excited how do you feel about
Looking for Alaska getting banned from
several high schools in Tennessee yeah
bad I mean that stuff used to make me
really angry now it just makes me sad I
said a book in you Tennessee this is how
you repay me so I came here in the 39th
floor of my hotel and there is a rope a
rope no no if there's somebody above or
below me but I'm afraid for them and a
little bit for myself I would go to the
edge of the room and look but I can't
get too close to the window or I get
nervous back to question Tuesday would
you go on Dancing with the Stars
no it combines two of my least favorite
things reality television and dancing in
front of people would you be okay with
the United States becoming more like
Canada well if you mean living in a
country where people who have longer
healthier lives are more likely to be
employed less likely to experience
sexual violence than I guess so but if
you mean putting a queen on our money
hell no at what age did you hit puberty
well I didn't really hit it so much as
I'd sort of gently bumped into it but
that was about 14 exactly how bad is
your eyesight well it's just a little
bit better than my dad's and one time
when we were kids my dad lost his
glasses in the ocean when we were at the
beach and later we were watching TV and
he said hey John could you move those
clothes and I said dad that's Hank
favorite book of the year so far behind
the beautiful forevers Henry's first
word hi favorite movie Harvey what a
wasp's exists why do you exist favorite
infinite set real numbers favorite
Beatles album white favorite youtuber
charlie is the Union nerdfighter
yes meaning of life helping favorite
Shakespeare playing I mean stuff
I think my thumb I said Hamlet so this
time I'm gonna say Macbeth are you
afraid of sharks yeah why do you think I
live in Indianapolis we've got awesome
shark insulation pineapples or people
mmm that's tough both pineapples and
people are kind of prickly and they both
manage to somehow be simultaneously too
sweet and too sour but I think I'm gonna
go with people just because I find them
more physically attractive but on the
other hand you can eat pineapples
now I'm gonna stick with people I mean
you can eat them in a pinch will you
cast nerdfighters in The Fault in Our
Stars movie right so I know this sounds
weird but if Fox makes a movie of The
Fault in Our Stars I will have exactly
as much say and casting as you will and
the reason they don't trust me to make
those casting decisions is that I should
not be trusted with that decision
because in my mind Drew Barrymore is
still like 16 years old I'll be like why
not Jennifer Lopez for hazel and that
charming young up-and-coming Hugh Grant
for Augustus so yeah if they make the
movie it'll go how it always goes which
is that we'll all find out about the
casting will all be upset about it and
then we'll go to the movie and we'll be
like oh my god Jennifer Lawrence was the
perfect Katniss and then we'll be in
love with Jennifer Warnes but not in a
creepy way although we do follow her tag
on tumblr he said referring to himself
in the first-person plural how do i
gently tell a boy that i'm not
romantically interested in him I have
exactly one piece of relationship advice
use your words hank dftba i have to go
give a speech to some librarians but i
will see you on Friday
scary Oh
why does it move so much